hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is the 2016 macbook you can tell because
it's pink so this one should be pretty
quick there's not a whole lot of
difference between this guy and last
year's first generation in fact i'd
hardly call this a second generation
product at all it's essentially just a
spec bump inside it's like a version 1.2
of the 12-inch macbook but almost
everything else you'll find about this
guy is the same as last year so you have
the same exact paper thin dimensions the
13 millimeter thin super light two pound
body
the same low travel butterfly key
backlit keyboard the same really large
really nice force touch track pad the
same incredible sounding speaker with
the full width grille still don't know
how they made it sound that good but
it's still here and the same 12-inch
retina display the only difference on
the outside is the new color available
the rose gold
yeah 2016 you're the pink tech anyway
what's different is on the inside this
year it's basically just getting a spec
bump to the new skylake intel core m
chips it's actually a pretty significant
upgrade in the performance department if
you take a look at it you can now pick
between a 1.1 gigahertz core m3 or go
all the way up to a 1.3 gigahertz m7
that turbos all the way to 3.1 gigahertz
so much faster cpu and gpu performance
is nice plus faster storage as well the
internal ssd is now getting you around
400 plus megabytes per second writes and
800 plus megabytes per second reads
which is great so it's faster there and
for the record there's also a very
slightly larger battery inside it's
about a five percent more dense so not a
huge deal but better performance and
better battery life with the new chips
without getting thicker or heavier
that's a win-win and that is exactly it
that's everything that's changed
honestly like i said it's a pretty quiet
refresh i would have loved to have seen
at least a tiny little change on the
outside because here my two biggest pet
peeves with this laptop are still here
of course there's just one port and
there's still that 480p webcam so you
would think that they could at least
throw in one more usb type-c port now
that it's later in the year and it's
becoming more mainstream there's more
accessories starting to use usb-c now i
saw a pair of usbc headphones the other
day so i think the chromebook pixel a
whole year ago actually had it right
with a usbc port on each side just two
ports but it makes a big deal when you
want to use an accessory while charging
or just plug in two things at once with
the macbook you'll still need to carry
adapters and that in a way kind of
defeats the purpose of having such a
thin and light and beautiful computer
and then yes the 480p webcam is also
still here i think you could have
upgraded this to apple it's 2016 so if
the smartphone in my pocket can have
this huge 4k sensor with optical image
stabilization in this thin body you
could have fit a 720p sensor in the new
macbook just saying anyway so this
little refresh it isn't going to change
your mind about the macbook if you
weren't already going to get one it's
not that big of a change obviously it's
more like if you were on the fence about
getting the last one well this one's
better for sure so i'd recommend it
obviously over last year i think i would
still recommend the 13-inch macbook pro
to people still looking for a bit more
performance but for a thin and light it
doesn't get much better it doesn't get
much thinner or much lighter so the
baseline 12-inch macbook is a neat
little machine and a lot of fun so
that's basically it thanks for watching
this one and i'll talk to you guys in
the next one
peace